eSports ist heute eine globale Multimillionen-Dollar-
Industrie, die sich in einem
explosiven Tempo
bewegt
ziehen ein Publikum an, das mit den größten
traditionellen Sportveranstaltungen mit
Preispools von über 20 Millionen Dollar
für eine einzelne Veranstaltung mithalten kann. In diesem Film untersuchen
wir, wie alles in Nordamerika begann, wie es
sich entwickelt hat und wohin es
in Zukunft gehen kann, und das ist dasselbe, wenn
es so ist  ein Finale, wenn es nur ein
Spiel in der Gruppenphase ist, ich bin die ganze Zeit konkurrenzfähig und
ich liebe dieses konkurrenzfähige
Gespräch mit den Menschen, die
es am meisten leben und atmen
[Musik]